hello everybody until Brennan we're
going slender hunting right now I was
apparently he's too stupid to know that
the space bar was a freakin fire button
so Wow where is he where is he where is
he where is he I missed I miss bad
what is this doom and sorry that you
guys couldn't hear me before I kind of
forgot to crank down the volume but this
one should be good
where are you uh what that right boom
yeah I think I got it but it's not dead
yet hahahaha
I have the power now Oh what that uh
boom yeah yeah yeah yeah I will destroy
you sandy I have a gun a big boom banger
it should boom ease where are you where
are you
come out come out wherever you are
anybody back at the mansion maybe nope
can't go in there man it is noisy in
here where'd he go
I actually don't see him anywhere after
I shot him the first time he kind of
just popped right back up but now he
seems to be missing
Slendy I will end you ha [ __ ] you boom
got ya it's dead finally no I can whoa
what an ordeal man Wow can't believe I
survived that so I can't wink very well
I wonder what's gonna happen now that
Slendy is dead and no ever coming back
Bret stop Fred I guess I'm just walking
back to the house or something I don't
know
Oh Oh No come on
[Applause]
I knew it was coming
still startled me I tried to move my arm
and there's no feeling and when I look I
see there's nothing there something warm
is flowing down my fingers pain is
flowing all through my back
life is flowing out of my body pain is
flowing out with my blood a good the
ground is red and moist where I'm lying
God in heaven teach me how to die dying
is the one thing we all learned birth
there's something something profound I
don't know
San Jose Woods the end or is it lead
developers I cough any good jobs I
coffee you did a good job you should be
proud of the work that you've done here
and thank you everybody out there so
much for watching
but it's not over yet it's not over yet
because there's another mode sorry to
skip out on that yes abort this game
there's another mode pave collecting
bonus hang on I got a hand I gotta see
something there was a question mark yeah
still still yeah abort
page collecting we're gonna go a little
bit of the bonus find six pages it's the
first one looks like a page don't Jim
Brown me don't think I don't know what
you're up to
okay so page finding mode just like it
should be like classic arcade slender
you know classic mode oh look it's a
page I'm just Hey oh that is ominous I
wonder if I beat this mode if I'll be
able to get whatever that question mark
was okay not at the bottom of that Lake
apparently fly one in here
Hey look a key page page no page really
what got oh it's at
yeah yeah I guess I just got to wander
around through all the landmarks the
major landmarks anyway so I think I'm on
the outer edge this should be the cave
up this way when I swing back it'll be
the win or the saw thing yeah that way
leads to the saw and then I think that
breathing it's just me you know after I
sprint ah he's there oh he's there
forsaken you're damn right you are and
for good reason too could you're a
douche ah why I can't see him ah man he
pumped about in there huh give it
another go go right this time maybe it's
like the other games and sprinting
attracts of attention I don't know when
I was playing the normal game it kind of
just helped out to get away from him
because it was easier that way
I think I might have just not seen him
and run smack dab into him that's
probably what happened hey look is a
page II page
he never saved
I like the different music I don't
really well I say I like them I say I
say I mean I appreciate them for what
they are it's good well-made music
doesn't mean it's good as in you know
reassuring or anything like that all
right another landmark maybe another
page the other page page page hey do not
slow down you're damn right no go this
way got that there's a thingy there
mansions coming up swing back around hit
the sawmill or something cabe blah blah
blah then I win then I win right it's
just that easy
ooh battery I didn't realize I'd have to
pick that up
never slow down never slow down don't
slow down
only sprint in little bursts and you're
okay you'll be okay you'll be okay
you'll be okay you'll be okay I'll be
okay I'll be okay just don't turn around
oh god I gotta turn around after this
mansion a Paige Paige Paige Paige Paige
Paige Paige Paige Paige Paige Paige
Paige Paige Paige Paige Paige Paige
Paige Paige [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] oh
there's another pass oh god I I'm dead
I'm dead I'm dead I'm dead I'm dead I'm
dead I'm dead I'm dead I'm so dead
ooh I don't remember this before what
the hell is this
Paige okay three winner not yet but I'm
gonna die but okay I'm okay with that
don't get me Slendy don't get me don't
get me just letting the easy dick oh I
didn't know this led to the cave oh let
me go in the back and then I can get out
the front I've quite better for my
survival chances aha age force shaken oh
boy
for I got to get to the sawmill and then
the rocks to the beginning I think
probably those are where the other two
pages are I think this leads to the
sawmill if I'm not man is it getting
dark
all my flashlights must be dying I think
this leads to the sawmill I'm not sure
oh god I am lost I'm going to die oh
here we go
what I click got stuck on something
God alright one more try
dammit I don't know what I got stuck on
I don't know
alright same rules ok moving forward
don't die
good rules for life okay pages are
randomized maybe it's on the other side
of the building Kenneth
oh it is oh good thing I checked else I
might have been screwed means I gotta
check everything everywhere okay that
pile leaves looks familiar
but this way leads to where I need to go
flip flip flip left left left left left
left hip diplom and was there a page
here or not I don't remember I gotta
look anyone I think there was behind
these boxes but not this time
fudge fudge nutters okay okay there's
another pile of leaves there this way
leads kind of this battery and then back
into the mansion nothing here hey don't
be rustling leaves I'm the world
champion relief Rustler don't think you
can compete with me I don't know what
that was
he's there auch rabbi over sprinted oh I
had two pages by now before I'm kind of
screwing myself over oh oh he's there
he's there he's here he's right there he
is right there he's gonna get me hey I'm
boned maybe not maybe not maybe I'm okay
maybe I'm okay there's no page here
either
I'm boned bone I don't I don't have one
page I don't know where the other pages
could possibly be oh no no I got screwed
over on the last game I was stuck on an
invisible wall
it's all your fault Jeremy you know who
I'm talking about that's a fun game I'm
scared I'm just gonna I'm just gonna
start calling out random names to creep
people out right what's not ready for
that hmm
okay so Paige collecting mode is hard
apparently so very very hard anyway oh
that's it for now I'm gonna I'm gonna
take a break from that I still haven't
beaten the Slender eight pages so I'm
not gonna break my head against the wall
trying to beat this one if there's
something really special after that
question mark then let me know in the
comments below I'll play it off camera
until I beat it and then I'll just get
to the UM
I'll get to the special super secret
mode but just let me know so I know what
to do so thank you all so much watching
I hope you enjoyed this amazing story
driven adventure forces slam down
because it's good to see a story coming
to play I mean there's there's a certain
level of creativity in the free-roaming
at making that work but actually having
something like a story is phenomenal
it's really good so thank you ladies
thank you thank you so much for hanging
out with me and watching so thanks again
everyone for watching click the
annotation more videos that I've done
and as always I will see you in the next
video bye bye